hey i'm chad
and in this video we're gonna unpack how
to say the right things
in a conversation and in particular i'm
gonna share
three key ideas
on how to say the right things in a
conversation
every time by the end of this video you
are going to feel like
at the end of every conversation and the
people you're in conversation with
are going to feel like you just said the
right things at the right time for the
right context
and so it doesn't matter if you're in a
funny conversation with a friend
or a serious conversation with a family
member
or a really intense conversation with a
co-worker this video will share three
key ideas that will help you
say the right things in conversation
every time let's get into it
[Music]
one time i was at a restaurant with my
wife and kate and two friends
and uh i got up to go to the bathroom
and
somehow i bumped into somebody i don't
remember exactly how this was it was
outside the bathroom i bumped into
somebody
his name was greg he was with three
other people their names were amy
susan and cindy and about an
hour later we had finished our meal
everything was cool
and we walked back and i just said
hey greg hey susan hey cindy hey amy and
greg stopped me
and was like how'd you do that and then
he
didn't wait for me to answer the
question and then he said and he just
started answering his own question and
said
actually i know exactly how you
remembered our names
i guess greg was a construction worker
and he went on to tell me this story
about a guy named dominic
who he was doing a project on his house
for this multi-multi-millionaire and
every single morning when dominic would
leave the house
he would say hi to over 20 people who
were working
on his house people even there was at
least there was even one time where
someone was taking out the trash and
dominic said hi
by name to every single person as he
walked to his car
and one day greg stopped dominic and
asked him and said
dude how in the world you've got to tell
me how do
you do that and dominic looked at him
straight in the face and says you know i
don't remember names
because you don't care enough i was like
boom i think there are other reasons
maybe that you remember names but the
point is in order for these
three key ideas that i'm going to share
on how to say the right things in
conversation
you have to actually care about the
people you're talking to
you can't fudge this you can't you can't
manufacture and just say the right
things and because
part of the idea of saying the right
things in conversation
is being as authentic as possible in
that conversation
and so if you're putting on some sort of
face and trying to be
something or trying to do something else
it's not going to click or resonate with
that person and so in order for these to
work you've got to
care as dominic said he did the idea
number one
is reflectively listen
reflective listening is an extremely
simple and underutilized
tool um but it's it's phenomenally
useful because it allows you
to just hold up a mirror to the other
person
and reflect back what they're saying and
so if you want to say the right things
in conversation don't try to come up
with that yourself
use the person's words the person
sentiment etc
you can check out this other video with
a whole breakdown
of four different levels of reflective
listening and how to do them
but in this video just the short bit is
hear what somebody's saying not just
their words but the music behind the
words
the sentiment what you're noticing what
you're observing and just reflect that
back
you can reflect it back verbatim what
they said or
simply translate what they said into
your own words and feed it back to them
it is a phenomenal what happens in our
brains
when we're fed back words or ideas that
we shared
but didn't even really process until
somebody spoke them back to us in the
same way that you don't know
that you have a booger or a raisin in
your tooth until you walk into a mirror
and you see that for yourself and when
you gain that awareness of what you're
saying and what you're doing
it's oftentimes the exact right thing to
happen in a conversation
key idea number two is turn assumptions
into questions right assumptions are not
fundamentally bad
they are so natural it's really useful
that we make assumptions oftentimes but
the key to saying the right thing in
conversation
is to not act on those assumptions or
speak as if those assumptions were true
so to say the right thing in a
conversation if you do have an
assumption
recognize that an assumption is just a
story that you have
and then turn that assumption
into a question not rooted in any
judgment and
ask it sometimes when you're trying to
figure out the right thing to say in a
conversation
it's a question to unpack and further
dive into the conversation
when you're thinking about how to say
the right thing in a conversation you
don't want to
be really concerned with what you're
saying out of this device
you want to be more concerned with how
you're using these two appendages on the
side of your head
and being deliberate in the questions
that you're asking because
people are rarely asked questions
based on what they've just said so often
in conversation
it goes sentence ends in a period
sentence it ends in a period sentence
ends in a period
when we break that mold and somebody
says a sentence that ends in a period
and we fire back a question
it feels great right i haven't met a
single person on the planet that doesn't
want to be
seen heard and understood at some level
so it's really really phenomenal
to be able to be asked about what we've
just shared
the third key idea here is to master
empathy
the most common metaphor for empathy is
standing in somebody else's
shoes i would say and my
co-author uh will would also say that
empathy oh that's really awkward empathy
is not standing in somebody else's shoes
empathy is putting one of your feet
into that person's shoes
but keeping one foot grounded in your
own reality because
if you have both of your feet in both of
those person's shoes
i would argue that that is sympathy
you've you're totally lost in their
reality
and you can't actually know the right
things to say in a conversation and so
that's what happens when we hear
something sad happen for somebody
and you get that like that like pitiful
like it doesn't really make you feel
better it's kind of
it almost just like spirals um the
sadness i would say that
that's uh sympathy whereas if you're
able to be empathetic
and have really try to see the world
from their perspective and i would say a
really practical way to
make empathy happen is to describe the
world as
they see it when you describe the world
as they see it right that might be
rooted in some of your assumptions
but it also that person is feeling like
you're attempting to
understand them in a really empathetic
way
as opposed to knowing how they feel
because you have
both of your feet in their shoes at the
exact same time
i exist on the planet to gently
eradicate
small talk and create conversations that
matter and so
a lot of the stuff that we've created is
available if you want
the paper version or the actual paper
that products you can get that
but a lot of stuff's available for free
below because i would much rather live
in a world
filled with wonderful conversations
filled with empathy and reflective
listening
and meaningful dialogue as opposed to
screaming yelling and judgment
if you liked this video you will super
love
the two videos here um but more so
you'll love
a lot of the free tools resources that
we have linked below
hope you enjoyed this video have an
awesome day
you